>>> HAVE A SEAT, EVERYONE.
PAY ATTENTION.
OR IF YOU'RE GOING TO BED OR
WHATEVER, PAY ATTENTION.
>>> NORTH CAROLINA CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE'S CAMPAIGN AD TELLS OF
STORY OF WHEN THE KKK CAME TO
TOWN.
THEY STOOD UP TO THE HATE GROUP
AND DROVE THEM OUT.
>> THE NIGHT THEY RODE IN WITH
THEIR CARS, THEIR CROSSES AND A
SINGLE LIGHT BULB HOOKED TO A
CAR BATTERY.
50 KLANSMEN.
HE HAD BEEN A TAIL GUNNER IN A
B-29 DURING THE WAR.
LOCKLEER WAS FOUR MONTHS
PREGNANT.
HUNDREDS OF NORMAL FOLKS
DECIDING TO STAND TOGETHER
AGAINST IGNORANCE AND HATE.
LOWRY SHOT OUT THE LIGHT.
THE KLANSMEN SCATTERED.
BY THE TIME THE SHERIFF ARRIVED
TO FISH THEM OUT OF THE SWAMP,
THE PRESS WAS RUNNING WITH THE
STORY.
THE BATTLE OF HAYES PAWN, A
PIECE OF HISTORY WORTH
REMEMBERING, ESPECIALLY TODAY.
>> BOY, DO WE NEED MORE FOLKS
LIKE YOU NOW.
JOINING ME IS CHARLES GRAHAM.
HE IS RUNNING FOR CONGRESS IN
NORTH CAROLINA'S NINTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
I'M SO GLAD YOU REMINDED US OF
THAT, AND IN THE PROCESS REMIND
AMERICANS OF IT.
I APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
GOOD EVENING.
>> THANK YOU, DON.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> SO WHAT A STORY HERE.
WHY DID YOU MAKE "THE BATTLE OF
HAYES POND" SUCH A CENTRAL PART
OF YOUR CAMPAIGN?
>> DON, THIS ROLLOUT YESTERDAY,
ACTUALLY, WAS INTENDED TO
DEMONSTRATE TO THE FOLKS IN THE
NINTH CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
THAT THEY HAVE A GENTLEMAN WHO
IS RUNNING FOR THIS OFFICE WHO
HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT WHEN
COMMUNITIES COME TOGETHER, AS
DID HAYES PAWN,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, INDIANS,
COMING TOGETHER TO FIGHT HATRED,
BIGOTRY, WE CAN ACCOMPLISH A LOT
WHEN WE DO THOSE THINGS AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT WE SEE TODAY.
>> YOU SAY THAT WHAT HAPPENED
THEN MIRRORS A LOT OF WHAT WE
SEE TODAY.
EXPLAIN.
>> WELL, DON, ON A SMALLER
SCALE, I DON'T HAVE TO IDENTIFY
WHAT THE KKK STOOD FOR.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT THEY STOOD FOR,
HATRED, BIGOTRY.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO 2021, I
THINK THE WORLD KNOWS WHAT
HAPPENED AT OUR NATION'S
CAPITOL.
WE HAVE A DIVIDED COUNTRY AS WE
SEE TODAY.
I'M A CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS AND I WOULD USE MY
VOICE TO STAND FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT, TO STAND UP FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY.
AND MY SITUATION, WE HAVE A
SITTING HOUSE MEMBER WHO HAS
UNDERMINED OUR PRESIDENCY, WHO
HAS UNDERMINED -- AND I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU, DON, HAS TURNED
DEMOCRACY ON ITS HEAD.
CHARLES GRAHAM, I WAS RAISED AS
A SHARECROPPER'S SON.
MY GRANDPARENTS WERE
SHARECROPPERS.
I WAS TAUGHT VALUE, HOW TO TREAT
PEOPLE WITH RESPECT, AND THOSE
ARE THINGS I WILL TAKE INTO
CONGRESS TO WORK IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY TO MAKE MY COMMUNITY, THE
HOME OF THE LUMBEE, A STRONGER
AND BETTER COMMUNITY, AND THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT A MUCH STRONGER AND
BETTER COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WOULD BE
ADVOCATING FOR AS OPPOSED TO
WHAT WE SEE NOW FROM MANY OF OUR
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> SINCE YOU MENTIONED THE
OPPOSITION, YOU'RE RUNNING
AGAINST THE CURRENT REPUBLICAN
DAN BISHOP.
DAN BISHOP WAS BEHIND THE
INFAMOUS BATHROOM BILL THAT BAN
PEOPLE FROM USING RESTROOMS THAT
DID NOT CORRELATE WITH THEIR
BIOLOGICAL SEX, LIMITING IT FOR
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE.
YOU APOLOGIZED TO THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY AND TOLD
THEM THE VOTE WAS A JOKE.
WHAT CHANGED YOUR MIND, SIR?
>> DON, THAT WAS APPROXIMATELY
FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I VOTED FOR
THAT BILL.
I DID NOT REALIZE AT THE TIME
WHAT WOULD BE THE OUTCOME OF
THAT LEGISLATION.
I REALIZED AFTER THE FACT THAT
IT WAS HURTFUL, IT WAS PAINFUL
TO OUR TRANSGENDER COMMUNITIES,
AND I MADE A CHOICE THAT WAS THE
WRONG CHOICE.
I'VE APOLOGIZED FOR THAT VOTE,
AND IN ADDITION, DON, I DID WORK
DILIGENTLY TO REPEAL THIS BILL,
AND I'M PROUD THAT I'VE DONE
THAT.
I'M AN INDIVIDUAL WHO, DON,
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE, ESPECIALLY
MY YOUNGER LIFE, I EXPERIENCED
HATE.
I EXPERIENCED DISCRIMINATION.
I CONFRONTED IT FACE TO FACE.
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND GOING
INTO CONGRESS, IT IS MY
INTENTION TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
PEOPLE OF COLOR, GENDER WILL
HAVE A VOICE IN CONGRESS AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW, PARTISANSHIP AND DIVIDE.
>> WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
PARTISANSHIP AND DIVIDE.
DO YOU THINK THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SELLING, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BUY
IT?
>> I THINK AS A MEMBER OF THE
NORTH CAROLINA GENERAL ASSEMBLY,
THE CONSTITUENTS I REPRESENT,
THEY WANT TO SEE THEIR MEMBER
WORKING ACROSS THE AISLE, TRYING
TO BRING THINGS TO THEIR
DISTRICT, AND I'VE DONE THAT.
THE HOUSE MEMBER THAT I'LL
HOPEFULLY BE RUNNING AGAINST,
DON, I DON'T KNOW THAT WE CAN
SAY WHAT HE'S BROUGHT TO OUR
FOLKS IN EASTERN AND RUHLE
COUNTIES.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU I HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO BRING
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE PEOPLE THAT
I REPRESENT, AND I'M VERY PROUD
OF THAT FACT.
SO MY VOICE WOULD BE A VOICE AS
A UNITER, NOT A DIVIDER.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE IN THE
CURRENT SITUATION.
SOMEONE WHO HAS UNDERMINED OUR
PRESIDENT, WILL NOT SUPPORT HIS
AGENDA, AND I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
APPRECIATE THAT.
>> REPRESENTATIVE GRISHAM, I'M
SO HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ON.
I HOPE YOUR MESSAGE GETS TO
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY
VOTE -- REPRESENTATIVE GRAHAM,
EXCUSE ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I SAID THAT,
BUT GRAHAM.
I HOPE YOUR MESSAGE GETS TO
PEOPLE, WHETHER THEY V